but what happened before the big bang
what happened before creation
is there a white hole on the other end
of a black hole
can time go backwards are there other
dimensions
are there other parallel universes out
there is there a multiverse of universes
these are all questions that are beyond
our present understanding
what is the problem that you're trying
to solve with a theory of everything
well i first encountered the problem
when i was eight years old
a great scientist had just died it was
in all the newspapers
and all they did was to publish a
picture of his desk that's all they did
published a picture of his desk and on
that desk was a book
that was opened and the caption said
the greatest scientist of our time could
not finish that book
well i was stunned what
why didn't he ask his mother why didn't
he simply treat it as a homebrew problem
what he couldn't finish it so i went to
the library
and i found out this man's name was
albert einstein
and that book was the unified field
theory
the theory of everything an equation no
more than perhaps
one inch long that would allow us to
quote
read the mind of god well i was hooked
i had to know what was in that book what
was so hard
so when i was about 17 years of age i
wanted to be part of this great
revolution
i went to my mom and i said mom can i
have permission to build an atom smasher
in the garage
a 2.3 million electron volt beta tron
particle accelerator in the garage
and my mom said sure why not and don't
forget to take out the garbage
well i took out the garbage i got 400
pounds of transformer steel
22 miles of copper wire and i built a 6
kilowatt
2 million electron volt betatron
accelerator
in the garage now every time i plugged
it in
i would blow out all the circuit
breakers in the house
so my poor mom she must have said
why couldn't i have a son who plays
baseball
maybe if i buy my basketball and for
god's sake why can't he find a nice
japanese girlfriend
why does he have to build these machines
in the garage
well i went to the national science fair
and i met an atomic scientist there
dr edward teller father of the hydrogen
bomb
and he offered me a scholarship a
scholarship to harvard
so i took it and then when i graduated
from harvard
he offered me a job and that job was to
design
hydrogen warheads to be part of
los alamos and livermore national
laboratories
well i respectfully and graciously
declined that very generous and kind
offer
because i wanted to work on even bigger
explosion
i wanted to work in something even more
powerful than a hydrogen bomb
and that is the big bang
the creation of the universe i wanted to
find the
god equation the equation that set
the big bang into motion that created
the big bang
that caused the bang to happen you see
we just know that there was a bang
that's all we know that's all we know
there was a bang
we don't know why it banged how it
banged we don't know anything about the
bang other than
the fact that there was an expanding
universe anyway so i said to myself
that's what i want to work on rather
than designing hydrogen warheads
why has this equation proved so
difficult to discover
well because it wants to find a single
paradigm
a single principle a single theme
that explains the entire diversity and
richness of the universe
now the greeks thought they had it
democrats thought it was adams
but pythagoras said no no no no it's
music only music has the richness
to explain the diversity of all the
forms we see
in mother nature pythagoras saw a liar
string one day
he plucked it and the longer the string
the lower the note
and then he went by a blacksmith shop
and they were making swords
the longer the sword the lower the sound
had made
and then he said mathematics
the mathematics of resonances can
explain
music and he was right pythagoras is the
founder
of our understanding of the mathematic
the mathematical basis
of music well today we think the music
of subatomic particles
explains the entire universe now let me
explain
if i have a super microscope and i look
at an electron
most people would say the electron is a
dot but you see
we don't think so we think that it's
actually a rubber band
and it vibrates when it vibrates one way
from a distance we call it an electron
you twang it
it vibrates another way and we call it a
neutrino
you track it another way it becomes a
quark you try and get enough time
it becomes all the zoo
this zoo of subatomic particles that we
see
so physics is the harmonies just like
pythagoras thought
physics is the harmonies you can write
on vibrating strings
chemistry is the melodies you can play
on interacting strings the universe
is a symphony of strings and then what
is the mind of god
the mind of god is cosmic music
resonating through hyperspace that is
the mind of god
why are we struggling to get from where
we are now
where we have standard model and we have
quantum theory
what why don't those two things just
nicely slot together well all of biology
can be explained in the language of
chemistry
all of chemistry can be explained in the
language of physics
all the physics in turn can be explained
as you pointed out
with relativity the theory of the big
black holes big banks
in the theory the small that is quantum
theory
the theory of lasers and transistors the
internet this conversation
is made possible because of the quantum
theory
now the problem is why should god have
two hands
a left hand and a right hand and they
don't
like each other they're based on
different mathematics different
principles different concepts
relativity is based on smooth surfaces
trampoline nets for example smooth
surfaces
while the quantum theory is based on
chopping things up
chopping things up into particles
they're opposites
in almost every sense of the word so how
do you combine it
well the greatest minds of our time have
tried to combine it
and have failed until recently
now we realize the unifying principle
between
smooth surfaces and chopped up surfaces
is music the lowest octave
of the string gives you all of
einstein's theory and
the standard model of particles that to
me is
amazing for free if einstein had never
been born
for free we would have discovered all of
general relativity as nothing but the
lowest note
the lowest octave of a tiny vibrating
string
to me this is absolutely stunning for
free we get the entire universe
and there are higher resonances these
higher octaves we think could be dark
matter
could explain what we see in the big
bang
so these higher notes also exist and we
think that most of the universe is made
out of dark matter which is invisible
but we think is the fotino which is a
higher vibration
of the photon does it has to be
is there inevitably an equation of
everything
is it possible for the universe to have
differing theories of big and small and
that just be the way it is
well to me it's absolutely amazing that
on one sheet of paper
on one sheet of paper you can write down
einstein's equation that's half an inch
and then
the standard model which is really ugly
clumsy
it's a theory that only a mother could
love but it works what can i say
it works i like to think of the standard
model with quarks and leptons and yang
wheels particles
this zoo i like to think of it like
taking an aardvark
a platypus and a whale scotch taping it
together
and declaring that to be nature's finest
evolutionary achievement
the end product the millions of years
of painful evolution on the planet earth
look the standard model has 36 quarks
and antiquarks
23 parameters three identical generation
of particles
it's so ugly that only a mother could
love it but it works
it worked at the low energy realm it
works until
last month last month
headlines around the world in physics
in physics laboratories when they found
a crack
the first crack in 50 years
in the standard model so the standard
model works at low energies
up to 14 trillion electron volts the
energy of the large hadron collider
but there's a new theory out there we
think
a higher theory a fifth force a fifth
force
and we think that it could be the force
of the string
but we'll wait and see of course this
result is very new
but it's shaken the world of physics
because for 50 years we've been stuck
with this ugly theory
called the standard model but you cannot
argue with the fact that it works
can you use the energies can you sink
more into
that recent discovery explain what it
was that was found and the implications
well every uh well there are three
generations of identical
particles in the standard model which is
bizarre why should mother nature have a
redundancy of three
anyway the electron has two partners one
of them is called the muon
it weighs 200 times more than the
electron but otherwise is
pretty much identical to the electron
now the electron has spin
so it's like a magnet it has magnetic
properties so does the muon by the way
the mu1 is found in cosmic rays
right now muons are going through your
body a lot of cosmic rays are in the
form of muons going right through your
body
even as i speak you're being irradiated
by cosmic rays
in outer space anyway the point is that
the muon also has magnetic properties
but the standard model says they should
be identical
identical to the electron but they're
not
two groups have now verified the fact
that the muon
has a differing magnetic moment than
predicted
by the standard model so this gigantic
foundation that we've built
has this huge crack in it meaning that
there's a higher theory out there a
higher theory
and we think this higher theory is
mediated by another particle
this other particle in turn creates a
force a fifth force
and we think it could be the next octave
the next vibration
of the string though of course time will
tell
but that is big news
it seems to me like there's constantly
progressing understandings of what we
know
about everything but a theory of
everything would only explain everything
that we know right now
surely then we would perhaps discover
more about the universe
and then need to then theoretically
describe the more that we found
how do you know that this theory of
everything is going to be the one the
only the final no more
said and done draw a line under it well
let's take a look at the next
layer of unsolved problems we have
einstein's theory we have the quantum
theory
but what happened before the big bang
what happened before creation
is there a white hole on the other end
of a black hole
can time go backwards are there other
dimensions
are there other parallel universes out
there
is there a multiverse of universes these
are all questions that are beyond
our present understanding and cannot be
resolved using the standard model
and general relativity but string theory
can resolve all of them
string theory takes you before the big
bang
it takes you to the other side of a
black hole it takes you to other
dimensions
other universes a new picture is
emerging
this picture given to us by einstein is
that the universe is a bubble
we live on the skin of the bubble and
the bubble's expanding
that's called the big bang theory string
theory says there are other bubbles out
there
there's a multiverse of bubbles
bubbles that collide with other bubbles
giving a bigger bubble
or bubbles that cut in half giving you
two smaller bubbles
in fact stephen hawking called it the
space-time foam
that space itself is foamy at the
subatomic
level and these bubbles can become
entire
universes and so string theory says
there was a world
before the big bang the big bang is just
our universe but the other universe is
being created
even as we speak even as we speak
universes are being created and so
string takes
string theory takes you way beyond
einstein's theory
and there are gateways gateways between
bubbles
called wormholes which by the way was
actually first introduced by einstein
himself in 1935.
the creator of the einstein rosenbridge
is albert einstein
and so there are bridges between our
universe and other universes
so then the next question that i get by
email is
is elvis presley still alive in another
parallel universe
and the answer is well probably yes
probably there is another parallel
universe we can't
of course enter that universe easily but
there probably are other universes where
the king is still belting out hits
after hits after hits
one thing i think so this takes you way
beyond relativity that's the point i'm
making
yes yes i understand one thing i've been
considering
given how much time you've dedicated to
springfield theory and mathematics and
physics over your career
how do you deal with the pain of not
being around for future discoveries
well there's a universality to
physics that you can appreciate at any
age
when i write down an equation i'd like
to think that on the other side of the
galaxy
there's also an alien that's writing
down the same equation
in different notations and that to me is
absolutely
stunning a revelation the fact that you
could be on
another universe another galaxy and
discover
the same equations now would they
discover and appreciate the work of
shakespeare
the work of hemingway the work of james
joyce
well maybe if the aliens studied english
really really hard
but for the most part these are cultural
artifacts
not to say that they're not relevant i
think they're very relevant relevant to
the human experience
but that's it relevant to the human
experience if you are not a human or you
don't speak english you can't appreciate
shakespeare
but physics is universal it's a language
that you could be of any age
anywhere and appreciate that this is a
universal
theory that we're talking about and that
doesn't make you
feel do you have fomo about the future
developments i know that i do
i think about how cool do i have what
phone whatever
fomo fear of missing out so
the desire to want to be here when we do
get the theory of everything or when we
can
transport ourselves on laser beams
across the galaxy
i get that i wondered whether you did
yeah well you know there's a scene in
back to the future
where doc brown says he's all wanted
he's always wanted to see
beyond his ears in other words
he's always wanted to see the future
even after he's gone
okay and now he has a time machine where
he can do that
but you see look at it this way we are
now witnessing the greatest transition
in the history of humanity
humanity for the most part for thousands
of years lived in the swamp
the swamp of witchcraft sorcery science
is only 300 years old
and we are privileged to be alive with
this exponential explosion
of knowledge in other words if i were to
pick a decade
if i were to pick an era where i would
like to have been born
this is the cusp the cusp i think we're
at the hockey stick the inflection point
right now
yeah so i think further up of course
we'll have even greater wonders
but you know you only you only see these
wondrous things for the first
time once for the first time
once you learn about atoms you learn
about relativity you learn about the
quantum theory
you don't learn about the quantum theory
twice it's discovered once you only
learn about it once
we live through that era once
so we are privileged to be alive i think
to be at the cusp
of some of the greatest revolutions in
human history
i'd like to think that the decade is the
smallest unit of history
anything smaller than a decade is a
random fluctuation
but then if you look at the decades gone
by the last few decades have been
absolutely staggering in terms of what
we know about
the universe so again if i were to
choose which decade to live in
i think i would choose these decades
because they represent
the the hockey stick the inflection
point where we just are just
taking off with regards to understanding
things it's a good reason you realize
that
you realize that our grandparents our
grandparents if they were to see us
today
they would think of us as being
sorcerers what you can talk to someone
instantly on the other side of the world
and visit them in 14 hours with an
airplane
that's unheard of for our grandparents
right and our grandchildren
would probably we would probably think
of them as gods
but the inflection point is now
what do you consider mathematics to be
is it universal is it some sort of
underlying
fundamental nature of how the
how reality exists i think it's more
than that
people sometimes ask me well where did
the universe come from well it came from
the big bang where did the big bang come
from well it came from the god equation
the solution of the god equation is the
big bang and then they say
well where did the god equation come
from huh huh
and you keep on going where did that
come from where did that come from
and then you eventually have to deal
with the question of pure mathematics
you see i personally think that the god
equation exists
and is unique it's unique because it is
the only mathematically consistent
theory
now the amazing thing about string
theory is that it's only mathematically
consistent in 10 and 11 dimensions
in four five six dimensions it's not
consistent if you have a five
dimensional string theory
you can prove that two plus two is five
now obviously two plus two is not five
but there
there it is the proof of mathematical
proof if you start with string theory in
five dimensions
two plus two is 5. in other words what
i'm saying is something simple
string theory is because it's the only
self-consistent mathematically
consistent universe
it is unique why because as soon as you
deviate slightly from string theory
you have divergences it blows up and
anomalies
symmetries get broken so as soon as you
deviate the slightest mathematically
from string theory
boom all hell breaks loose in other
words
the universe is because it is the only
mathematically consistent universe
all other universes two plus two equals
five
ours is the only universe where math
makes sense
einstein said that if you can't explain
a theory to a child it's probably
worthless do you think that string
theory fits that criteria
yeah you know when when children are
born we're born
scientists we want to know where we came
from where the stars shine we want to
know everything
and then we hit the greatest killer of
scientists known to science
the greatest killer of scientists known
to science is
well public education when you're around
13
14 15 years of age at that point it's
all
memorization just memorization
we lose young bright scientists by the
millions
every day because they're forced to
learn things that they know are totally
irrelevant boring
so how should you teach it the way
einstein thought
using things that children understand
that is principles
concepts things that stay with you
because they're pictorial they have a
picture take a look at news and laws of
motion
it's all about balls hitting other balls
balls circulating around
the balls look at einstein's theory
relativity it's all about meter sticks
levers pulleys
stop watches it's about things you can
touch things you can measure
and what is string theory music
so the point of raising is something
simple these are things that children
can understand children can understand
oh yeah that's how newton's laws work
forces
act over balls that bump into each other
you can understand einstein when you
realize that space and time is a fabric
these are all pictorial and then string
theory says everything is reduced to
music
children can understand that so that's
why i think that all great theories are
pictorial
conceptual with a principle and all the
useless theories are just pure
mathematics
yeah have you got any thought
experiments
that we can do to explain how we get
into a higher dimension what a higher
dimension
might look like i know look is probably
the wrong word to use here
but how can people envision us getting
out of
three and into four or more dimensions
well when i was a child i used to go to
the japanese tea garden in san francisco
and there's a pond there with carp
swimming in two dimensions
i used to stare at them for hours they
could go left right
forward backward but up up into the
third dimension
is beyond their understanding there is
no up
in their world and then i imagine there
was a scientist fish a scientist fish
would say ba
humbug there's no third dimension what
you see
is what there is what you see is the
pond
the pond is two dimensional that's it
end of story
there's no third dimension and then i
imagine grabbing the fish
lifting the scientist fish into the
third dimension
what would the scientist fish see he
would see
beings moving without fins a new law of
physics
beings breathing without water a new law
of biology
now what i'm telling you this is that
many physicists not everybody but many
physicists believe that
we are the fish we spent all our life
in three dimensions going forward
backward left right up down
but anyone who dares talk about a higher
dimension a fourth fifth sixth dimension
is considered a crackpot a crazy a
mystic
a magician but actually we think that
the universe is probably
10 or 11 dimensional why because we have
four fundamental forces
gravity electromagnetism and the two
nuclear forces
in three dimensions they don't fit
together like a jigsaw puzzle
you try to put the equations together
and they don't fit
einstein spent 30 years trying to push
gravity
and electricity and magnetism into one
theory and he failed
so i like to think of it this way in
hyperspace
there's enough room enough room to fit
all the four forces into one theory
i like to think of it this way at the
beginning of time there was a crystal
a beautiful gorgeous crystal that was
three-dimensional
but it had a flaw and it had a flaw in
it and it cracked
and it shattered all the pieces onto a
sheet of paper
on that sheet of paper the flatlanders
flatlanders saw this
shower of pieces of crystal landing all
over their world
and they said let's put it together so
after many many
hours and years of work the flatlanders
finally assembled the pieces into
two chunks one chunk they called
relativity
the other chunk they called quantum
theory but they didn't fit
in two dimensions it didn't fit and so
they were frustrated
and then one day a flatlander had this
outrageous
heretical preposterous idea
why didn't you lift lift one of these
pieces into the third dimension
and turn it around and put the two
pieces together
and would fit just perfectly well the
flatlanders laughed and laughed they
said what
there is no third dimension it's a
figment of some imagination or
or some science fiction novel there's no
third dimension
but in a computer in the computer they
could lift
one piece turn it around in the third
dimension
and the crystal fit perfectly in other
words what i'm saying is something very
simple in hyperspace
there's enough room to fit all the
jigsaw pieces together
to create one jewel that is
the super force that created the big
bang
the original flatland book when i read
that i really really enjoyed it
it feels a little bit like plato's
allegory of the cave
you know where you have the heretics you
have this
unknown banished insight
about the world that's not supposed to
be it's not supposed to be seen it's not
supposed to be spoken about
i uh i think you can get it for free
online it's downloadable.pdf anyone
that's interested in the original
flatland story
it's really really interesting um and
also i should point out that artists
have been fascinated by this because
it's a new way of seeing reality
salvador dali was fascinated by the
fourth dimension
he went to brown university and actually
buttonholed
friends of mine thomas banshoff
mathematician you wanted to know
everything about the fourth dimension so
if i take a hypercube
well i'll tell you i take a box a
cardboard box unravel it
if i unravel a cardboard box what do i
get across
well if i take a hypercube and unravel a
hypercube i get a three-dimensional
cross
a tesseract and so salvador dali
painted jesus christ crucified in the
fourth dimension
it is one of his great paintings
hypercubicus crucifixion
google it and you'll see jesus christ
crucified on a four-dimensional
unraveled hypercube and what is a
signature
image of salvador dali melted clocks
melted clocks was his way representing
the fourth dimension
the fourth dimension of time in his
canvas in his works of art so you see
artists have been fascinated by these
higher dimensions
because higher dimensions represent a
sliver a sliver of a higher
reality also if you saw the movie
interstellar with matthew mcconaughey at
the end of the movie
he winds up on string theory at the end
of the movie matthew mcconaughey is
floating
floating inside a hypercube why because
that was a hollywood's attempt
to have matthew mcconaughey float in the
11th dimension
and of course it's very difficult to do
that in a two-dimensional screen
but that's as close as hollywood can get
and so they have matthew mcconaughey
floating in a hypercube
in the final scenes of the movie
that's the most dolly thing that i've
ever heard arriving
at some poor mathematician's office and
bothering him until he gets his answer i
i recently gave a
tedx talk and i did a lot of research
about dali for it
did you know that his parents thought he
was the reincarnation of his dead
brother
who had been born nine months before
that with the same name
so they gave birth to someone called
dali
and this child died sadly
and then the new dali was born and he
believed and they believed
that he was the reincarnation of his
dead
sort of infant brother which i mean when
when that's how your life begins
it probably makes a fair bit of sense
that the rest of it's going to be non
non-typical to say the least
also when you look at picasso
cubism cubism in some sense is also
based on the concept of the fourth
dimension
because you're talking about the the
fact that you're looking at an object
through a different lens
and the lens is the lens of the fourth
dimension and so cubism also was
inspired
by the fourth dimension and around the
year 1900
around the year 1900 a lot of christian
theologians had a problem
telescopes were becoming more powerful
they looked in the heavens
and they asked a question where is
heaven
everywhere they looked they couldn't see
heaven and so
that led clergymen with a problem for
generations they were saying that heaven
is up there
but now telescopes became popular and
there was no up there
and so where did heaven go hyperspace
and that's why theologians christian
theologians at the turn of the century
wrote treaties treaties about higher
dimensions
because that is where heaven is located
it's the hyperspace of the gaps going on
there isn't it
hyperspace that's right that's where
that's where it all takes place
why do you think the planck scale exists
why is there a smallest measurement of
anything
well the greeks asked that question what
is the smallest interval
zeno had that famous paradox that to go
across a river
you have to go through the halfway point
to go to the halfway point you have to
go to the quarter point
the eighth point well how many points
are there when you cross a river
an infinite number so if it takes a
infinite amount of time to go through an
infinite number of points
then nothing can move nothing
can move because to move you have to go
through an infinite number of points
which takes an infinite amount of time
therefore nothing can move
and of course it was calculus the coming
of calculus that finally got around that
but now physicists are coming back to
that again
what is the shortest distance possible
and we think the shortest distance is
the planck length
the shortest time is the planck time the
shortest energy is the planck energy
now what is that the planck energy is 10
to the 19 billion electron volts
that is a quadrillion times more
powerful than the large hadron collider
outside geneva switzerland
in other words it is the big bang
it is the energy content of the smallest
distance
which we think is the big bang itself
and then the question is how do we make
sense of the fact that there is a
smallest distance
okay well this is where string theory
comes in people want to know how big is
the string
right if a string vibrates and it's an
electron
vibrates another way it's a neutrino
well how big is it
it is the planck length so in other
words
there is a shortest distance the
shortest distance is given by string
theory
and is that because it's a building
block is it right to think of it like
that like a fundamental
smallest pixel size of existence in
string theory you cannot go
smaller than the planck length in fact
when you you when you even try to get
smaller than the planck length
another universe opens up which is the
opposite of our universe
so another universal so in other words
it's the reflection of our universe
right when you go inside a string so in
other words you cannot get smaller than
a string that's the point of making
so i'm not saying that string theory is
correct i'm saying that if it is correct
it means that there is a smallest
distance
oh and also let me answer another
question people often say well
let's say i don't like string theory
give me an alternative
well there is none now that doesn't mean
string theory is correct
but it has no alternatives you see a
unified field theory has to satisfy
three criteria three criteria you solve
it and you become the next einstein
first you have to include relativity
second
the standard model with electrons quartz
neutrons protons
and third it has to be mathematically
consistent
string theory satisfies all three no
other theory
can make that claim let me repeat that
again people have tried
for a hundred years people have tried
but no other theory can satisfy these
three criteria
so if one of your listeners ever finds
that one-inch equation
that satisfies everything more powerful
than string theory
what should you do email you you should
tell me
tell me first and we'll split the nobel
prize money together
we'll go down in history you and me if
you're going to find that one
equation now string theory can be
summarized by an equation an inch and a
half long
that's my equation that's called string
field theory however now they're
membranes
which is a spoiler we now realize that
strains can coexist with membranes
and so we want a field theory of strings
and membranes so far we don't have that
sorry about that so that's where we're
stuck right now but that's a
mathematical problem
so i think that some young enterprising
kid out there
could mathematically solve it and tell
me first
i will make sure that some sort of
contact detail like you need like a
9-1-1
sos i've got it line
available 24 hours a day in man one of
the maddest things
that i learned so your new book got
equation one of the craziest things that
i learned was
a single sentence in there and it's that
max planck's son
tried to assassinate hitler yeah that's
right
is that amazing what on earth is that
well punk was a very in some sense
mild conventional person he followed the
rules
and he stumbled upon the quantum theory
one of the greatest theories of all time
sort of by accident and when hitler rose
to power
he actually visited hitler and tried to
argue with hitler
but hitler just blew his top and said
the jews i can't tolerate jewish
physicists
and pluck was saying you're destroying
physics all the jewish physicists are
leaving
are leaving germany he didn't care and
so
plank was ever the gentleman the irony
is
he lit a tragedy of isla a tragedy that
his son was tortured
tortured by the nazis because the son
tried to assassinate hitler and so
um planck lived through world war ii but
it was a life
of tragedy in some sense tragedy of war
even though he himself was not a
revolutionary he was
a very mild very polite kind of person
he didn't like controversy i mean he
didn't like to get in the middle of a
heated argument
but his own son tried to assassinate
hitler
that's right crazy absolutely crazy
why do you think we have super voids
i've been
learning about the super void
which is this huge big hole
essentially in the visible universe have
you got any idea why we have these
massive voids
oh you mean in the uh cosmic microwave
background
i think it's to do with more to do with
the mapping of galaxies
that there are these big chunks where
you would expect this uniform
uniformity of distribution between the
galaxies
and we have these supervoids where there
are large swaths of
space and very very few galaxies which
is
not what should be predicted right you
should have that uniformity
yeah there are two kinds of voids one
the void that you mentioned is the void
when you look at on a galactic scale
that the the density of galaxies is not
totally uniform
the other gap is when you look at the
cosmic background radiation
which should be totally uniform it is
basically
a baby picture of the shock wave that
gave birth to
the big bang the cosmic microwave
background that also has a gap in it
and we're not talking about cosmic gaps
in the structure of the universe itself
some people think these are evidence of
an umbilical cord
an umbilical cord connecting our infant
universe to a parent universe
so you see we're going to launch a
satellite called lisa which may answer
many of these questions
this is the laser interferometry space
antenna the european space agency and
nasa
is backing it it'll detect gravity waves
from the instant of creation not
400 000 years after the big bang no the
instant
of the big bang it's going to give us
baby pictures
we're going to get baby pictures from
the infant universe
and maybe just maybe we'll find evidence
of an umbilical cord
an umbilical cord connecting our baby
universe
to a parent universe if that's true
there has to be a birthmark we have a
belly button
so what we what we could be looking at
is the belly button of the universe
now again this is where we have to have
a new theory
the old theory simply says there was a
bang it doesn't say why it bang it
didn't say howard bang
the big bang theory just says there was
a bang okay
however string theory should also say
how it banged why it banged and
therefore if there's an umbilical cord
there should be some scar left behind
and some people think that could be the
origin of these gaps
but again that's just a theory i suppose
if you're talking about the
foam and the bubbles the intersecting
bubbles and the
fissioning bubbles as well as those were
to pull apart i imagine that that final
moment as well would also potentially
be a reason for that or the collision of
universes too
universities can collide and if so there
should be a remnant
a scar in our universe and how would we
find it
we would find it in the density of
galaxies and the density of the
microwave background radiation
that's where the scar would be how
is this cosmic scale how big is this
lisa thing how is it going to work
is about a million miles across think of
three satellites
connected by laser beams making a
triangle
the triangle picks up vibrations from
the instant of the big bang
and jiggles jiggles these three
satellites
that causes an interference pattern
which can be photographed
and so by looking at interference
patterns we can then detect
the get a baby picture
of the infant universe as it's being
born
now take a look at ligo ligo
does the same thing except these
detectors are separated by a few miles
now we're talking about going to outer
space where detectors can be separated
by
millions of miles not just a few miles
like in ligo but millions of miles
giving us a sensitivity to understand
the instant of creation
you see ligo is a gravity wave detector
gravity waves go right through the haze
of the original big bang
microwaves do not therefore when you
look at the cosmic microwave background
when you get a haze that's all it is you
get ripples on the haze but it's a haze
no structures you don't get a feeling of
what happened at the instant of the big
bang
that's where lisa comes in it's going to
give us baby pictures of the instant of
creation
so some people say that we're not going
to be able to prove string theory
that's not correct there are many ways
of proving string theory one is by going
to lisa
finding out what happened at the
incident of the big bang another one is
finding out about dark matter what is
dark matter it could be the next octave
the next octave of the string and what
about cracks in the standard model is
there a fifth force
well maybe just last month we found
evidence of a fifth force
and four the chinese
the japanese and the europeans are now
proposing the successor to the large
hedron collider
which may be powerful enough to reveal
uh the next octave of the string
and lastly higher dimensions can be
measured
by looking at deviations from the
inverse square law
when you're in high school you learn
that if you double the distance between
you and the star
gravity goes down by 4. why because 2
times 2 is 4.
it goes down by the square why the
square
why not the cube why not the quartic the
quintic the septet
because space is 3-dimensional but in
your in your living room
if space has a higher dimension the
inverse square law should be violated
as small distances now people have never
done that they've never really looked at
deviations from the inverse square law
in your living room
but that's the next set of experiments
was isaac newton correct
not on a galactic scale but on the scale
of your living room
that could be evidence of a of a higher
dimension
in your living room do you know where
they're planning on putting lisa
is it going to be in between us and mars
have you got do they have to
reserve some it'll be the sun
it won't orbit the earth it'll orbit the
sun okay
and it'll be three satellites launched
into outer space connected by laser
beams
and it'll be orbiting the sun rather
than orbiting the earth
because it is really a detector for the
ages for the universe itself
with nothing to do with the earth at all
so it'll be orbiting the sun
now the fundy was approved but it's been
delayed
but google it lisa and you'll see that
um it's gone through several
incarnations
but the thrust of it is to get baby
pictures of the instance of creation
and also what happens when black holes
collide these generate gravity waves
where are they going to put this new
version this new super hadron collider
where's that going to be have you got
any idea
of the location of that well the
japanese have proposed uh japan as the
place for it
uh called the ilc international linear
collider in japan
but if japan has the highest number of
earthquakes
in the world so
you have to be a little bit careful
there uh that's like putting slack
uh the stanford linear accelerator
center near the san andreas fault
in california
they had to put the accelerator on
rollers to compensate for earthquakes
that periodically ripple through
california
the same thing probably with the
japanese accelerator they probably have
to put it on rollers
to realign it every time there's an
earthquake
that is very funny that you have to
account for the fact that the earth's
going to move as you're desperately
trying to detect something from a couple
of billion years ago
i know that you're not a believer or at
least you are a skeptic of whether or
not we're living in a simulation
i wondered whether you could explain
your justification for that
yeah very simply um what is the smallest
object that can realistically model
the weather let's say i i take a
fishbowl
of air what is the smallest object that
can mathematically
model that well of course newton's laws
of motion say that there's lots of
trillions of atoms
you have to mimic the emotion of each of
these atoms
and you begin to realize that no
computer on the earth can do that
the smallest object that can model the
weather is
the weather itself anything smaller
would violate the the universal gas law
the simple properties of gases
and so that's just a pure gas now try to
simulate
us try to simulate reality
and then add the quantum theory the
quantum theory makes it a lot worse
that's just that you have trillions of
possibilities you now have
infinite possibilities with the quantum
theory
and so that's why i'm saying that the
people who believe in the
simulation theory don't understand
quantum mechanics
that even newtonian mechanics makes it
impossible to simulate reality
and quantum mechanics makes it even
worse because you have to take into all
possible universes
in your simulation as well for example
when you look in a mirror
you're not really looking at yourself
when you look in the mirror
you're looking at yourself as you were
about a billionth of a second ago
because that's what it takes for light
to go from you to the mirror and
back about a billionth of a second and
it's even worse
because you are a wave you coexist with
an infinite number of waves
and some of these waves drift off even
while you're talking to somebody
some of these waves wind up on mars
tomorrow
in fact for our phd students we give
them the question
what is the probability that they'll
wind up on mars tomorrow
it's calculable use the heisenberg and
study principle
and you find out that you have to wait
longer than the lifetime of the universe
to wind up on mars tomorrow but it's
calculable
if you could if you could live longer
than the lifetime of the universe
then one of your versions of you will
wind up on mars tomorrow
so with simulation theory it gets worse
and that's just the quantum theory of
you to simulate a city
a metropolis with people in it
just boggles the imagination as to
what's required quantum mechanically
so in other words we do not live in a
video game where somebody pushes the
play button and here we are moving
there's no play button for the universe
uh science is based on things that are
testable falsifiable reproducible
the simulation theory is not testable
not falsifiable and not reproducible
so it doesn't qualify as a science now
that doesn't mean that it's not
interesting
it just means that it's outside the
boundary of science
it's sort of like god can you prove or
disprove the existence of god
i don't think so it's outside of science
like can you disprove the existence of
unicorns
no you cannot disprove the existence
of unicorns because no matter how good
you are at searching through
the earth maybe it's a unicorn hiding
someplace
so you can never disprove the existence
of unicorns
so you can never disprove the existence
of god and you can never
disprove the simulation theory which
means
it's not a science but it's fun to ask
and it's fun to think about
it is like thinking about god
it's not a measurable testable quantity
let me give you another example
a reincarnation you mentioned
reincarnation before
i was at a party once and a woman said
that she's cleopatra the reincarnation
of cleopatra
so i answered some simple questions and
she got them all wrong
about cleopatra but then she said
that doesn't matter i am cleopatra
and all the history books are wrong
at that point she stopped me cold cold
she stopped me
and i said she's right if
she is cleopatra all the history books
are wrong
so how can i disprove her and i realize
that this is beyond science you cannot
disprove that
you cannot disprove the existence of
unicorns you cannot disprove the
existence of clairvoyance i mean of
reincarnation as
is there a term for that particular type
of bias is it just unfalsifiability
uh yeah it's outside the boundary of
physics it's metaphysics
metaphysics is what is beyond physics
and physics of course is based on things
that are testable
reproducible falsifiable that's how we
know that when you jump off a building
gravity is going to take you to the
floor
you're not going to float if you jump
off a building right
so that's physics but that's not
reincarnation
angels how do you disprove the existence
of angels you can't
they're things that are outside the
boundaries of science because science is
only based on
testability reproducibility
falsifiability
angels are not quantifiable they're not
testable
and they're outside the boundaries of
science that doesn't mean they exist
it doesn't mean they don't exist either
it just means science says nothing
about them it feels like
that unfalsifiability paradigm that
you've just explained there is being
used by a lot of people
at the moment a lot of people in 2021 to
explain all manner of
of things one and
you've talked a lot about futurism and
considering
our potential descendants
behavior as we move forward have you
considered the ethics
about somebody deciding that they're
going to board
a long traveling ship
so you're going to spend you as a human
are going to decide that
you will volunteer to travel to alpha
centauri and it's going to take
10 000 years let's say at some
particular speed
have you considered the ethics of that
person making that decision
and essentially cursing or blessing
their children to be born live and die
on a ship
well that question has many parts to it
i'm trying to figure out which part you
want me to address
just have you considered the ethics of
whether or not what it would be like for
somebody to make that decision
about whether or not it is even an
ethical decision to be made like should
we should we be permitting people to
make that sort of a decision for unborn
humans yet
i'm aware that it's not something that
we need to be concerned about just yet
but given the fact that it is something
we need to do at some point
well there are many facets to that
first of all
first of all the dinosaurs did not have
a space program
that's why they're not here today they
couldn't leave the earth
so when an asteroid came it wiped them
out sorry about that they had no space
program
we do have a space program so when we're
hit by an asteroid one day
some people may say well we have a space
program let's go to alpha centauri
let's go there because the alternative
is to go the way the dinosaurs
then i think it's perfectly ethical to
say
well yeah we have the rocket ship let's
go to colonize a new planet we just
discovered a nice planet a doppelganger
of the earth
orbiting alpha centauri or proxima
centauri
so let's go there even if it takes you
know many many years to do that
so i think it's an ethical decision that
you know we need we need to have
plan b we need to have an insurance
policy
so that humanity can survive even if the
dinosaurs didn't survive because they
didn't have a space program
you know one of the most depressing
passages in the english language
was written by bertrand russell the
famous mathematician
who said that for all the greatness of
humans for
all the tears that we've shed for all
the bravery that we've exhibited
heroism it's all for nothing
absolutely nothing because when the sun
dies
the earth will die with it and it's the
law of physics
inescapable the sun will die and we will
die with it
well that was written in the 1930s today
we laugh at that
because well look that's the way the
dinosaurs went
we don't have to go that way we have
rocket ships
and so it becomes an ethical question
do we want to exercise that option of
going into a rocket ship and leaving the
earth so we don't have to die
when the sun dies in fact i think the
universe is going to die
the second law of thermodynamics says
that in a closed system
everything eventually decays rots
dies that's the second law of
thermodynamics
physics has a death warrant for humanity
that we will necessarily have to die but
you see
there's a flaw a flaw in the second law
of thermodynamics
i said in a closed system things
necessarily decay and die what happens
if there's an open system
an open system where you can have a
wormhole and escape to another universe
which is warmer
so leaving the universe is an option
that we have to think about trillions of
years from now
when the universe gets very cold when
the universe consists of black holes
dead neutron stars and nuclear debris
of leaving the universe because we will
have the energy to bend the fabric of
space-time
we'll have the planck energy and maybe
we'll find
a loophole in the second law of
thermodynamics
by building a dimensional lifeboat and
sailing to under the universe
another universe which is warmer and
younger
and we can mess up that universe as well
so we'll have two universes to mess up
so i think it is an ethical decision but
if the alternative
is the second law of through my dynamics
which is death
then i think it's an option that we have
to think about in the face of complete
annihilation it does make a lot of sense
and you're right as well the
no matter what time scale you decide to
look on as it stretches further and
further out into the future the
the outcomes are just increasingly grave
we need to get off earth okay we need to
get out of the milky way okay we need to
get out of and so on and so on
out of the universe yeah precisely at
some point that's where the god equation
comes in
the god equation is perhaps the only way
to leave the universe
is to master the plank energy
by the way let me just end one last note
if i have a microwave oven
and i heat up water the microwave oven
will eventually boil the water
if i crank it up some more the water
itself will ionize
and you'll have a bunch of ions you
crank it up even hotter
then the ions fall apart into nucleons
and protons and neutrons
you crank it up more and it turns into a
quark gas
a gas of quarks you turn it up more
and then what happens you just keep on
turning it up turning it up
at some point space becomes unstable
it begins to boil space
begins to boil just like water when you
heat it up
water begins to boil what is the point
in which that happens the planck energy
at the planck energy you turn it up
bubbles begin to form
and what are these bubbles wormholes
wormholes to other universes right in
your microwave oven
what is the energy the planck energy an
energy
quadrillion times more powerful than
the large on collider but it's a number
you can write on a sheet of paper
it's a number that an advanced
civilization millions of years more
advanced than us
may play with if they become masters of
the planck energy
then they can boil space and
create gateways to other universes
michio kaku ladies and gentlemen the god
equation a quest
for a theory of everything will be
linked in the show notes below
why should people go if they want to
keep in touch with the rest of your work
as well
oh also my website you can go to my
website mkaku.org
mkaku.org fantastic
thank you catch you later on thank you
very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace
you